Welcome to our version of The View we've
never done anything like it
this is crazy so much to talk about uh
uh I like everyone here I'm an insane
fan of the show and it's real it's a
thrill and a fan level
it's really cool to get to meet you uh
let's start with the first question we
talked about it in the last segment how
much do you worry about dying because
this show is such a big part of your
life they don't seem to care who they
kill when they kill them you never know
what's going to happen uh why don't we
start Caprice can you tell us what you
basically uh we're afraid of whether I'm
going to be naked again
you have no idea when you're going to be
naked it just you just turn the page and
it says no whether I have to go to a gym
or not
that ever do when I when I hang out yeah
but okay okay Maisie what about you do
you try and ever talk to the writers and
get hints about please tell me I'm going
to be okay this season I I stopped
asking them
being annoying I think maybe I shouldn't
ask them because I end up dead quicker
so
and then I turned to sucking up to them
and I'm like can I you know buy a drink
or do you want to go out some food and
they're like am I still being annoying
and I don't really know how to get
around the death thing but I'm doing all
right so far you're doing okay so far I
gotta
now it has been I've heard
that the writers and producers can be
cruel and I heard that uh Alfie they
pranked you with a script they they sent
they gave you a script that was a fake
script just to freak you out tell us
that story they did well I just had no
tact and was asking the whole season
whether I was going to die or not
because we get the scripts and the way
we get episodes one to six and then
we'll get the last four later on so I
asked them and they were just like
shrugging their shoulders sort of giving
me that and then um I
I went on holiday I had a three week
break and and I'd been given this fake
script where it was um I bran comes out
on the back of hodor's back in
Winterfell and says this is my
Winterfell not yours and stabs me in the
hearts and so I thought it was a great
way to go right
I thought I'd be memorable and um they
called me up while I was on holiday
saying so how do you like your ending do
you like it and I was like yeah it's
cool thanks guys you're like okay cool
how would you feel about uh being a
zombie next year I was like
yeah I can do that like okay how would
you feel about being a zombie with
absolutely no dialogue whatsoever
because I don't know they're like come
on man you being serious so yeah they
can be kind of cruel with them that's
not just kind of cruel that is so none
of that it was all Bs it didn't mean any
of it then
[Applause]
[Laughter]
uh John do you worry about getting
pranked I do
but My worry is that we're
underestimating these guys and My worry
is that a lot of people have been
pranked saying that they're gonna die
my worry
is that you're going to get 10 scripts
and that you're going to have Dynamite
stuff there's going to be there's going
to be scenes with people you've never
had scenes before amazing narrative Arc
you're going to emerge the hero of the
piece the day after please find script
amendments for episodes one to ten
changes made you're in a single frame of
it all the best
is that possible could that happen they
could do that they can do whatever they
want whatever they want
uh okay Sophie Sansa has been through a
lot just so much
before the season not real folks
Andy no oh sorry
Israel here's the baby
um
well you've been through so much and
before the season even begins it feels
like unrelenting are you hoping that
this season things start to
get a little cheerier well I mean we all
but
um it's Game of Thrones Conan I know but
I'm just thinking you can have one
episode but they're like that's a good
cookie you know
why can't there be one episode where
they're like I had a good night's sleep
me too anyone get killed not a one see
you next and then resume next week and
then we can all do like a bit of a song
dance yeah
[Music]
I like that song um it's original so uh
okay I have to ask you something uh
Maisie you shot how many for so long
your character was in filming in
miserable kind of cold conditions right
were you jealous that your captain got
to be filming in beautiful just looked
like a beautiful uh Spa crew including
Sophie and a number of the cast members
would disappear for like six weeks and
then come back and like yeah we had a
really amazing time in Croatia it was so
much fun and so if you would show me all
the videos like oh we're all just like
playing in the ocean
like really like really really mean
actually it hurt me so when I was told
that this year I was going to create
Croatia and Sophie listen
I was totally thrilled and there was
there was a single ounce like of my body
that felt bad at all I was like you know
what I'm gonna have an amazing time in
Croatia without you yeah
John the the fans of Game of Thrones are
very opinionated what is the strangest
thing that you've been confronted with
the the strangest opinion that you've
been confronted with
well it's a fact really more than an
opinion
um I was in London and a guy came up to
me and said oh Game of Thrones I went
yeah he said I'm a huge fan I went well
fantastic I'm really he said can I ask a
question I went you just have nothing
and he said um he says no I've just been
wondering um
um why are you still so fat
[Applause]
and I said
well what he said no no I just don't
believe it I just don't believe it I
mean I mean you're right up north you're
not eating anything you're trekking
across Landscapes and running from
things all the time you should be losing
weight I mean you should be losing
I said okay I said I I look this is a
fantasy shirt
we've got fire breathing giant dragons
we've got ice zombies we've got a woman
giving birth to a cloud
that you just don't buy yeah
what is your strangest uh confrontation
you've had with the fan well I I told it
earlier today I was standing having a
drink and this woman ran towards me with
her hand like that for my crotch a woman
a woman tried to grab your crotch yeah
and I said what are you doing Mom no I
didn't
what
she's here uh and so did she explain
herself well what are you doing I just
wanted to check there was something
there
[Applause]
so two hours later yeah
two hours later he pulled them out and
showed the whole bar yeah
how's this for you
uh Hannah you've had some trouble with
loose lips is that true uh maybe letting
some things slip about what's going to
be happening in a show and that's gotten
you in a little bit of trouble you know
I'm a real liability I think
I think I should not be trusted with any
knowledge and um no I went to I'd I
think I just finished filming season
five and I went straight to a friend's
birthday party
um and I told him that Jon Snow was
gonna die
um
what
what well let's set this up the door
opens I'm glad you made it John's still
gonna die yeah and he looked at me and
he looked so sad and he just said
because he loves the show and he was
like it's my birthday
[Applause]
ever but why are you telling me on my
birthday at my birthday party it was
yeah that's awful
uh
is he
uh uh Sophie you've been on the show
since you were what 14 13 13. you've
that's growing up fast I would think to
be on that set with everything that's
happening was that difficult to grow up
that quickly well yeah and also I mean
my parents sat me down when I was like
15 and they were like I think it's time
to talk about the birds and the bees and
I was like I'm on Kings bro
I
don't think I need any education there
I got it all sussed out
in the first episode I mean Tyrion and
Roz they're just going at it do you
remember that
you pop yes yes we remember that yes you
remember it
I'd have to remember
it's good when you rewind it too uh
maybe you almost missed out amazing you
almost missed out on your audition for
Game of Thrones is that true
I nearly missed out on my first Game of
Thrones audition because I wanted to go
on a school trip to a pig farm
it's really down for that
I was like oh I'm gonna miss a school
trip and I get to wear my own clothes
don't have to wear school uniform oh God
I didn't have to wear school uniform to
be auditioned
as a school girl everyone else
Natalie Comic-Con uh famous for uh you
know sort of fans geeks nerds whatever
they want to call themselves you are a
self-proclaimed nerd is that right yeah
I'm a bit of a nerd
foreign
you've taken it you have actual proof
that you are yeah taking stuff pretty
seriously science fiction yeah I mean I
have a I have an original I have an
original Blade Runner poster at home
which
I was lucky enough to get Ridley Scott
to sign when I work with him and I also
have a tattoo which some of you might
know this little novel sci-fi novel one
of the original
um from which all the shows we love
probably spun from is June yeah
we I'm being told we are completely out
of time we've had
[Applause]
sorry we are
only really give us an hour and if we go
longer than that it just smashes into
something else on this network I don't
remember what I don't know
uh yeah please don't yell at the answer
uh I want to thank everyone from Game of
Thrones I'm so sorry that uh we just
couldn't keep talking because I think we
could do this for hours
you know on last night's show uh we had
a treat we had the nine cast members
from one of my all-time favorite shows
Game of Thrones
and they were
loved that show
they were great it was a thrill for me
personally unfortunately we ran really
short on time I got to ask everyone in
the cast a question but we ended up
having to to break from the show before
I got to speak with Liam Cunningham who
plays Davos and I felt really bad about
that so I thought why not bring Liam
Cunningham back tonight
talk to him and yeah and guess what
ladies and gentlemen I called him
because I I felt so bad and I want to
apologize he agreed to return ladies and
gentlemen here he is Liam Cunningham
thank you thank you thank you so much
for coming back I wanted to ask you the
question I didn't get to ask you
yesterday with Melisandre arriving at
Winterfell do you think that Davos will
now seek to avenge Stannis
go [ __ ] yourself
I thought that went well yeah
seems touchy